what has happened is the argument
and you talk about this in a debt-free
degree yeah
in the best-selling book of yours the
argument
against the cost the extreme
exorbitant cost of a four-year degree is
even stronger
and was accelerated by covid because you
can't even freaking go on campus
right right and so it's basically you're
getting an online degree
and everybody's going well i sure as
crowd ain't paying that for an online
degree
right and i was questioning whether i
was going to do it with the college
experience
right but now when there's no college
experience and now it's all online i'm
sure
i could just go on google and get that
you know and so people are uh
that is forcing covet accelerated a
cultural shift
in us observing what's happening with
higher education so higher eds
um they're they're in a mess yes they
are and if the
biden administration goes through on
some of its promises and forgives
student loans
and yet has the hypocrisy to not
stop the student loans yes see if you're
going to forgive them because they're
evil
you shouldn't keep making them
absolutely agree dave
because they're evil yep you cannot in
good car i mean
it's intellectually dishonest to forgive
student loans and continue to make them
right that's straight up pandering
straight up politicians handing out
money
yeah that's all that is that's not a
philosophical
admission that the student loan crisis
is a screw job on the american public
yeah
and if you're going to admit that then
you need to stop making them which
they're not going to do by the way
they're not going to do that dave and i
know we we're
totally against debt but at least maybe
put a cap on it you know don't make it
unlimited for these
these people it's just out of control so
but that's what's driven the cost up is
this unlimited supply of stupid money
yes there's always somebody who will
take the money
yep and so you know government money
which
by the way you don't even have to pay
back if it's forgiven so i mean this
whole thing is getting
super absurd so the guy's question
question is really good
it's really because that pressure was
all there and then add covert to it
and you go we're not even on campus yeah
i'm sure not paying 50 grand a year for
this
right and people are starting to wake up
and go hey i want a return on investment
i want to pay
get something you know get something i'm
real proud of for what i paid for so
online learning
or reasonable state schools or community
colleges or
some of the stuff we've been suggesting
to avoid student loan debt for years
are suddenly much more popular but
that's going to change what the
offerings are at higher ed
yeah it really will over time so the
answer your question is zach if
if you said i'm going to put in 200 000
in my kids college fund this morning
i would say yeah i agree with you don't
do that because the landscape's changing
i might not do that all at once
but if you're going to start gradually
you're not going to screw up having 10
grand
under 5.29 so let's get started but then
continue to monitor the shift
in the education culture and what's
expected
so now dave let me ask you this question
uh you have several mutual funds
i have not several i have a couple
mutual funds outside of my roth ira
now let's say if he maxes out his 529
he's already investing in all the other
type of stuff
can would you suggest he opens up
another mutual fund if he just wants to
save more to give more to his kids and
he can just have that in his name though
okay and then that could be used for
anything yes yeah i mean you can just go
i'm gonna buy a piece of real estate
with it
i'm not giving it to the kid i got you
so you can just build wealth and that
always gives you options for doing
anything you want to do
got you a pile of money in your name i
would not necessarily pile a bunch of
money in the kid's name
okay you can if you want to
save some taxes but you lose a lot of
control uh
yep because see that mutual fund if you
put it in the kid's name it's called a
uniform um well i can't call it out yeah
my brain went blank but anyway
uniform transfer to miners act the booth
helped me out thanks guys
my brain's locked up but uniform
transfer to miners act and all that
means is
if you open a bank account with your
bank for your child to have
put their milk money in or their
birthday money in because little junior
has a little savings account at the bank
right that's under the uniform transfer
to minors act okay
because it's you can't technically open
an account
unless you're 21 anywhere you can't
because you can't do
you can't do business you can't you're
not an adult so the parent opens the
account in the child's name
typically and the parent is named the
custodian right and so
but then that mutual fund if we do that
is taxed at that kid's
rate so as it makes money it has lower
taxes than if it was in my name
got you i got you because i'm gonna get
my butt taxed off right i know that
right and so it saves you some but again
it's
it's their money right when they turn 21
if they're doing cocaine they can go get
the money yeah
and so you you lose a lot of control
over it until they're 21.
gotcha uh and so i you know for what
little tax savings there is i would just
open it in your
name and just book on but this higher ed
discussion
and we've had it with dr john dolone
who's got a phd in higher ed and he
comes out of the
the university world as served in
leadership in multiple different
universities
but we're all observing that this is a
uh
when when the dust settles on this after
covet on
what colleges charge and how many people
attend them physically
it's going to have change it's going to
have accelerated the change yes
that the student loan crisis started yes
and i don't know to what extent but
we're going to see something shift
absolutely to where you know my my
university university of tennessee at
knoxville with
30 000 students or got a guy sitting out
here with a michigan hat on the
university of michigan or the university
of
uh whatever kentucky or auburn or
alabama or
california or whatever it's going to
look different yeah and those are state
schools
yeah now if you if you fast forward you
go over into a super expensive private
school
they're going to feel it even more
because people are going to go look
the student loan thing is so bad that
the democrats forgave it so i'm not
signing up
right right because not many people are
so dishonest to sign up knowing they're
going to get it forgiven
right like i'm going to go get all i can
get so the government pays for it
i'm going to get on welfare because i
don't really want to work you know most
people aren't that
lacking in honor so that it's going to
affect it
if they do this forgiveness even if they
don't stop making them it's still going
to affect
the perception in the culture it has
changed it's changed permanently
and you guys check out anthony's book
debt free degree and check out the
borrowed future podcast on the ramsey
network
because it lays out in detail how
crooked and how
i mean filthy yes the student loan
industry is
especially and the government intent
behind it yes i mean it is
a colossal mess
it is an epic failure man
and uh you need to check it out and so
and
if you want to go to school and you
should go to school by the way education
is important i'm not
we're not a group that says you don't
need to go to college it's not worth
anything oh it's worth it it's better to
be smart than dumb it really is
so you should go but you need to be
smart about your education it's
obviously moronic to not be
so i you know in debt free degree will
help you learn how to do that
it's like i said it's a number one
bestseller